hi I'm Brian Schuster I'm the chief
executive officer of the virtual world
web and we're here demonstrating the
commercial consumer available holodeck
version 1 point 0 which were intending
to launch at this summer the holodeck is
a amalgamation of three really
interesting technologies the virtual
world web which you're seeing as the
visual and and curio which is the
browser which powers the virtual world
web and in conjunction with the oculus
rift which provides immersive experience
and visual and audio immersion and the
virtuix Omni which is an omnidirectional
treadmill that allows the user to
navigate through a virtual environment
just by walking and turning and with the
combination of these three technologies
we get some really neat and interesting
outcomes which is very similar to what
users are familiar with from Star Trek
where the oculus right now is
demonstrating with sort of cockpit and
cockpit type games what the virtual
world web and what curio really give the
oculus power is in normal environments
in everyday environments and sort of fun
and interesting and educational
environments so it's great for first
person shooter it's great for sort of
action the software is really dynamic
and allows for and it's designed to be
MMO gaming and so developers are able to
easily develop on in a very cheap way
and an inexpensive way i should say
they're able to develop MMO games which
include action fighting and and of
course because you have additional
mechanisms for navigating which don't
require a keyboard we really free up the
user to be able to use the oculus to its
full potential so available this summer
through the through the virtual world
web so you'll just go to go to virtual
world web calm and you'll be able to
download the curio
browser I'm using material browser
you'll be able to go to the store and
pick up the package which will include
membership to the virtual world web it
will include the full virtuix Omni that
will include the oculus rift the package
is scheduled to be priced at under a
thousand dollars and is slated to be
released this summer when all of these
technologies are supposed to be coming
out of development and into a consumer
ready mode